Hello Freak bitches.
Don't,
you know,
if you like read here it is.
Yeah.
Cause it's just so interest
starting to approach or the approach to
combat and everyday life should be the
same.
Oh well that's,
that's a,
that that's a approach to combat and
everyday life should be the same.
That's,
that's intense.
Yeah.
It's always a little too intense.
I have a real interesting
one on my Instagram.
I don't know if you can pull it up.
Is that the guy who touched
the girl for the first time?
That video?
No,
but uh,
it is a lady,
uh,
the holiday one,
but it's interesting,
you know?
Yeah.
Who is that guy that touched the girl?
Did you get permission to put them on
your part to try to take down that one
that you made me put up the Christmas one?
Yeah.
Isn't that,
that one's pretty interesting.
The one where the girl,
the one that you should,
oh,
when you ho Ho ho it up for Eczema.
So I mean,
it's interesting.
Watch it.
Okay.
What
are you doing man?
What is wrong with you,
you and your wife?
Well,
first of all,
you're both fucking hilarious.
She is.
But you guys are closed.
So specific.
Yeah.
You have the,
you guys have the funniest,
silliest fucking show because
you're both so specific.
Thanks.
Yeah,
like the,
the things that you just decide,
like you wearing a shirt.
Tom's wearing a shirt that
says just glass and on it,
I'm just glass and Brown.
Now glass in is a term that like hunters
use when they get up on a ridge and
they look for things.
Yeah.
So when I saw that I was like,
well that's weird.
Like what did you,
maybe you bought that convenience
store when you were in Alaska,
right?
Something like that.
Yeah.
This would be a silly
gimmicky shirt today,
but no,
this is a shirt like from
your fucking podcast.
It is,
yeah.
It's top tells the story.
Every week a week
we get submitted hundreds of emails
with links to videos like that.
Right,
right,
right.
I mean,
so many emails.
Have you seen this?
Have you seen the,
and the,
and the Internet is endless
pool of stuff to pull from.
And then we have this,
our producer blue band,
I don't know if you know that.
That's our producer's name.
Bam.
Yeah.
Cause it used to be red band.
He was a yellow band for awhile
and now there's blue van,
so,
so blue band.
Um,
then we'll go through a lot
of this stuff and edit down,
let's say like a five minute
youtube video until like maybe six,
10 to 15 second clips.
And so we're just always
looking at stuff and it's,
you know,
the,
we like a range of things are engaging us.
Well,
we got this hunter,
his name is Fred Eichler,
I think he's an avid bow hunter.
He bumped he oh bonds
with a traditional bow.
Like a recurve bow is,
that's right.
The one of the most preeminent,
a recurve bow hunters.
Yeah.
It's either a recurve bow
or a might be a stick bow.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's a totally,
it's incredible how
that technology evolved.
Yeah.
So there's a lot of these guys,
like this guy you were
talking about class and guy,
he still uses like one of
those primitive boasts,
but he's just good.
He can get away with it.
It says,
I mean there's,
bio is the incredible,
but in this video it starts with him.
Uh,
he,
he shoots a moose and it drops quick and
he fucking comes close to coming in his
pants.
Like he,
he makes a sound that you don't even,
you can't,
he goes like,
like,
like can you show it to us?
Uh,
yeah.
Are you allowed to play it online?
Did you get pulled from anything?
No.
Play it on Youtube and,
and we also play,
I mean,
the audio is what's incredible,
but then he starts talking
about glassine and he's like,
we were just coming around the meadow.
We were just glass and go.
And then we were like,
let's go,
let's go ask.
And he gives,
keeps going.
Glass,
glass,
glass and glass,
which is looking through binoculars,
which we discovered,
but then we played it so much.
People like,
I would post a picture of myself,
like I'm about to go on and be like,
are you glassing?
And like,
or you know,
like if you talk to somebody like,
what'd you do today?
I'm like,
oh,
I hung out.
And they were like
glassing and you're like,
yeah.
So then it morphed into
meaning like just chill.
Yeah.
And I dunno,
it just kind of picked up from there.
So I just have so many of these though.
Okay.
What's the deal with jeans
calling everybody jeans?
Like when you guys were on that
and you had to explain it to me.
Yeah.
You know what the latest
thing is with that?
First we had an electrician over at the
house and whenever you're in the house,
you know you're calling your spouse,
I'd be like,
Jane's do you know,
cause that's what I call her.
So then she walked down
the stairs and he goes,
gene,
would you like me to put the,
so he and we just let it go.
We called her jeans,
but then we started,
I'm going to Starbucks
and ordering our drinks.
It's just like a stupid thing
like that we told our listeners,
we do,
we do this regularly
just to amuse ourselves,
which is,
we'll call them jeans and
then say thank you mommy,
or I love you mommy at the end.
And no one ever,
the order happens so fast and it's so
like programmed that they never catch it.
Never say like,
what did you say?
So like when I,
when I pulled up like,
welcome to Starbucks,
what can I get for you?
It'd be like a,
hey jeans,
I want to get an iced coffee,
extra ice and what do you want?
A double tall sort latte.
Okay.
That'll be a six many words.
I'll be like,
thanks mommy.
And then I just pull up.
So we told them we did that.
People sent us videos of them doing it.
Fucking hilarious.
Like a guy like getting his,
uh,
he was talking to a bill
play place and he's like,
hey mommy,
I don't understand what this bill means.
And the other guy's like,
yeah.
So that first section,
like they don't even address that
you're calling someone mommy or jeans or
saying thank you mommy,
or I love you mommy.
They're like,
okay,
have a good day.
Like they just,
it speaks more to almost how
preprogrammed customer service becomes,
you know,
they're not even acknowledging that you're
saying something ridiculous to them.
No,
no,
they're not.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
But also like,
what are you saying when someone
says something like that to you?
You probably like,
you're so scrambled.
I think so.
Yeah.
Cause it doesn't make any sense.
It started off not making any sense,
but then it picked up
and made a lot of sense.
Yeah.
It's like,
well clearly you can talk English
and then it gets to the end.
He calls you mommy and you're like,
whoa.
What happened?
One time we called the,
uh,
the renaissance in Cincinnati,
the hotel,
because the year before,
before,
a few months before my son was born,
we were there for a wedding and
Christina had like a 32nd fart.
So we,
she's very pregnant.
We came back and we talked about it and
we decided it deserved its own names.
What's called the Cincinnati Fart.
Oh,
Jesus.
And we figured out what room number we
were in and we called the hotel and I go,
Hey,
can I help you?
I go,
I want a book.
I want to stay there,
but I want to commemorate
the Cincinnati part.
And she goes,
I'm sorry,
what was that?
And I go,
I want to stay in this room.
I think it's from six one eight,
because this Cincinnati
fart happened there.
And she goes,
I'm just having a little trouble.
What was that?
The what?
And I'm like,
this Cincinnati Fart.
And she's like,
can you spell it for me?
And I go,
yeah,
f eight.
And she stayed professional.
Like she was like,
oh,
okay,
I'll look and I'll see what I can show.
Yeah.
She didn't probably have cameras on you.
You can't go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Why you waste my time?
Well,
I did have a,
uh,
a flooring guy.
I go,
can you do this floor for me?
And he's like,
well,
I can send you some samples.
And I go,
great.
He goes,
well,
who do I send it to?
I go to your mom's house.
And he was like,
what was that?
And I go at your mom's house.
He goes,
my mom's house.
I go,
no,
that's the name of our,
our company,
your mom's house.
And I go,
yeah.
And he was like,
all right,
you have a good day,
and he hung up the phone.
I'm going to go like I was.
I wasn't trying to,
for him it was a totally normal,
I wasn't trying to be funny.
I go,
no,
that's the name of the
company and want to listen.
He was like,
okay,
okay.
You have a good day.
Like wow.
Yeah.
Okay.
Did you try it?
You let him hang up.
You should have said it's
actually the name of podcasts.
We tried to explain it,
but he was looking it up on iTunes.
It's very popular.
He was,
he was pretty quick with like,
Oh,
this is a joke,
and I go,
oh,
okay.
He grew up with a lot of your mom jokes.
Yeah,
he did.
He's not liking it and not buying.
It seems like,
uh,
a guy that just didn't get it.
Can you play Fred?
Do we will you plays audio?
The glass and Guy?
Yeah.
It's,
where do you have it on your tongue?
It's on youtube.
Okay.
What is the name of the video?
It's called Sam.
It's saved on his phone.
Tell you,
give me one moment.
I'll look down at the ice house tonight.
Sold out.
I'm at,
I'm doing dom Irrera show tonight and
you're at the laugh factory tomorrow.
Tomorrow with Duncan Trussell
and Tony Hinchcliffe.
Doodoodoo got a couple of bop,
bop,
Bop,
Bop Moose down on 22nd it should be it.
Okay.
Crank it up.
That looks like a compound bow.
Really
pull it out right there.
She couldn't tell it
was moving really quick.
Quick.
Yeah.
That's a compound.
Will see the,
the cams at the top of the boat.
That's not a permanent boa at all.
That's I'm super modern bow,
I think,
but this dude knows how to do this.
He's,
Oh yeah,
I know.
He's so professional.
Bowhunter I've seen this
guy on TV a ton of time.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's got a TV show that I watch.
Dude,
if you go over to my house,
you'd think I'm a crazy person.
You change your profile pic.
Yeah.
It's a silly picture of me with a
camera on my face hiding in the trees.
I'm trying to make sure
this is the right video.
I'm looking going through the trees.
Every one's life start,
but I can still see the
moon through the tree.
Blended in good.
We've got,
when does it get good at archery?
Archery moves down.
Yeah.
That was coming up
and I really like,
here we go.
Okay.
It's about that,
so you get the
full shot.
Wait,
it's countdown to the getting real funny.
I just spoke to her.
She's got to go down.
Watch her,
watch her.
She's going to go down right
through our law to Jesus.
I don't like this part.
[inaudible]
oh,
I was raised.
That is awesome.
We got out here early board.
Look,
this is why,
this is why we came up here.
We've been slipping along
this big huge meadow,
big long call meadow.
We'd been slipping along here,
just glassing juice,
glass and glass and all of
a sudden I hit even have,
I need to put my head in it on.
I'm like,
God,
we're just glass and
he's been cured by those.
Let's just keep going.
Let's glass.
Let's the guys.
I'm like,
holy smokes,
I've got a moose hook,
got a moose,
and I'm like,
oh man.
It's a bowl.
And I'm like,
no,
it's a cow.
We got a cow right there.
That was unbelievable.
We came right around this tree.
She was,
is a cow
significant than a bowl?
No.
Unless he only had a tag for a cow.
Oh,
it depends on why.
Why he shot a cow.
Not a,
not a bull.
Sometimes it depends on the unit.
Depends on how many cows they have
versus how many bowls they have.
They might want people to kill cows.
They probably want a certain
amount of cows to be killed a year.
They have weird,
um,
who decides that?
Yeah.
It's fishing game department.
They go that we have too many
of his entirely Thailand.
Where you are depends entirely on
what part of the world you're in.
And then do you report it?
Yup.
Yeah.
You Tag,
you tag and animal.
Let me save you a,
you shoot a moose that's a moose.
I this one I shot in British Columbia.
Really?
Yeah.
And you,
uh,
you have a tag and you take that,
you know,
you,
you have to pay it.
And they allot a certain amount of them.
Some places they have what's
called over the counter.
Okay.
[inaudible]
okay.